m und zwar einfach weil es damals war
dass beide hände unter der karte waren
habe ich meinen wer hält denn bitte
irgendwas so mit beiden händen da
drunter und nimmt dass da noch so wieder
hoch dass wir die runterfallen deswegen
ist eine hand da drüber und drunter
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zurück
zu einer weiteren folge minecraft facts
wie immer am anfang zu sagen ja es muss
nicht sein dass er jeden fleck tieren
und nicht kennen sondern es kann auch
sein dass ihr sagt ja ich kannte alle
vier sachen schon und ihr seid der
allerbeste ist alles über minecraft dann
bitte nicht einfach um helden und den
anderen sagen wie kann man das denn noch
nicht wissen sondern dann einfach mehr
an kontrast gmail.com wo wir auch jeder
andere zuschauer hier effekt in senden
kann einfach dann mit minecraft als
betreff infektion sein weil davon lebt
die serie von euren facts und wenn ihr
die irgendwo anders her schon kennt dann
kann ich da auch nichts durch greife da
komplett nur auf eure effekt zurück
bevor es jetzt losgeht mit den vier
vorgestellten fällt sie diesmal echt
cool sind und echt interessant
eigentlich möchte ich noch einmal dieses
was ich damals angefangen habe dass ich
immer so ein geräusch gesagt habe
nochmal eine nennung machen und zwar ex
gp 2002 ausrufezeichen hat letztes mal
als erster erkannt nach 25 sekunden
dass sich eine glasflasche aufgeschraubt
habe beim letzten mal das geräusch für
diese folge ist wo habe ich dann
hingelegt hier und zwar schreibt mir
jetzt in die kommentare
der allererste wird gewinnen was ist das
hier für ein geräusch ich mach's nochmal
und nochmal also freunde wenn ihr wisst
was das für ein geräusche schreibt in
den kommentaren eventuell werdet ihr in
der nächsten folge erwähnt und ich würde
sagen wir fangen jetzt auch direkt an
mit dem ersten tag der mit zugesendet
wurde von niklas römer oder
bloomberg.com organisierte falsch niklas
primas richtig und zwar nehme ich dafür
mal ganz kurz mir hier ein boot und eine
karte in die hand also erstmal ja komm
karte du kannst mal laden meinem app
sieht ja nicht sonderlich interessant
das ist es einfach nur so ein
vierteiliges ding und zwar wenn man sich
als athlet ist meine rechte hand das
ganz normal zu sehen
wenn ich fünf drücke ist natürlich nicht
zu sehen dass wir ein bisschen komisch
wenn die dann einfach so ein bisschen
höher werden
allerdings wenn ich eine karte in die
hand nehmen und die so halte und dann so
drauf gucke da verändert sich hier nix
aber hier ist meine linke hand über der
card und die rechte an unter der karte
also ich denke mal einfach dass es kein
fehler ist sondern dass minecraft das
extra so gemacht hat weil ihr seht schon
das ist eine coole animation in diesem
mai kräfte also darauf kommt und zwar
einfach weil es damals so war dass beide
hände unter der karte waren habe ich
meine wer hält denn bitte irgendwas so
mit beiden händen darunter und nimmt
dass da noch so wieder hoch dass wir die
runterfallen
deswegen ist eine hand darüber und einer
hand darunter also cool dass du das
herausgefunden hastig spiel dass gerade
im latest snapshot ich weiß nicht in
welcher besonders ist aber es ist auf
jeden fall ganz cool dass diese micro
stand jetzt da drüben ist und es ist
eine coole animation aber das ist auch
nur hallo chef geht das ja und zwar das
nicht nur beim bootfahren so sondern
auch wenn ich das so ganz normal mache
also beim notfall ist das nicht nur so
sondern auch wenn ich die karte so ganz
normal trage ist natürlich auch klar
aber auf jeden fall cool affekt und ich
denke dass einige von euch das noch
nicht rausgefunden haben so kommen wir
zum zweiten effekte mir von ihren kresse
zugesendet wurde auch an meine kräfte
gmail.com mail und zwar nehme ich mir
dafür einmal diese drei gegenstände
steige hier oben drauf und ihr seht
schon was ich aufgebaut habe der
hintergrund muss ich mich zu
interessieren nicht interessieren
das ist einfach nur damit man die
spinnenweben besser erkennen weil weiß
auf diesem morgen dingsbums ist nicht
sogar ist das überhaupt model ich weiß
gar nicht ist das kreuz ist das stimmt
und zwar erkennt es wenn ich irgendwie
etwas darauf lege auf spinnen weben dann
rutscht das natürlich nicht durch weil
diese blöcke haben keine gravitation
wenn ich da allerdings items
reinschmeißen rutschen diese items durch
das geht allerdings sehr sehr langsam
deswegen nehme ich mir das einfach
wieder zurück wenn ich allerdings einen
amboss oder irgendwas anderes was
natürlich die manchmal noch ein drittes
also irgendwie so ein thrombus oder sand
oder kies direkt darauf setzte fällt
jetzt nicht dadurch weil es quasi nicht
diesen schwung hat den es hat wenn ich
das so machen
dann fallen nämlich diese sachen ganz
ganz lang
dadurch fing an zu regnen dass der weg
beschleunigt das ganze natürlich auf
jeden fall ein spaß der regel macht ja
gar nix aber diese drei sachen fallen
dort alle gleich schnell herunter und am
ende ihr werdet staunen also anstatt
dass es darunter wieder normal
rauskommen wird es geht es gleich schon
bestehen und zwar passiert es dass diese
gegenstände sehe ich gleich moment ganz
sofort in altem verwandelt und dann
unten wieder als items rauskommen ich
weiß nicht findet ihr das cool oder
nicht so cool
die sache ist einfach minecraft gewinnt
immer mehr an was den sprung geschafft
habe hatte ich nicht gedacht
minecraft gewinnt immer mehr an realität
und gerade die solche spinnweben dass
sowas zum beispiel nicht runterfällt
allerdings tcc anbau zu runterfallen
was haltet ihr davon ist es auf jeden
fall ganz cool mit anzuschauen das unter
anderem auch ich hier durchfallen kann
und diese anderen sachen auch wenn die
dann nur um verfallen und dann als altem
stil heraus kommen auf jeden fall cool
kommen wir zum dritten factory von jan
zugesendet wurde dann kann dich jander
wäre glaube ich keiner von uns drauf
gekommen und zwar wenn ich eine tür mit
diesem normalen holz button öffnet
bleibt ja für eine bestimmte zeit offen
wenn ich die allerdings mit einem stein
button öffnet bleibt die kürzer offen
offen wenn da werde
wer das jetzt noch nicht ganz erkannt
hat also dass ihr scheiß egal mit
welcher sich das mache ich kann das auch
jemand machen
ihr seht ich drücke die ich versuche
jetzt mal relativ zeitnah zu drücken
und diese tür geht trotzdem schneller zu
obwohl dieser stein button danach
gedrückt wurde also hier nochmal sie
geht früher zu obwohl der steinplatten
später gedrückt wurde
andersrum sieht man das ganze noch
heftiger wie lange die dings offen
bleibt aber sie macht das jetzt mal ganz
schnell mit einem holz button bleibt
egal welche tür länger offen
ich kann euch das ganze jetzt auch noch
mal mit einem countdown machen als ich
nehme jetzt mal ganz kurz diesen stein
button
so und jetzt ein holz button
oder habt ihr gesehen dass ich hoffe ich
hab das hingekriegt irgendein zu beenden
ihr habt gesehen mit einem holz button
bleibt eine stadt eine tür
egal welche turbos diese tools oder die
holztür mit einem holz button länger
offen als mit einem stein button und ich
denke das ist auf jeden fall ziemlich
cool weil macht euch auf jeden fall ein
stein button wenn ihr jetzt nicht so
ganz flink seite microsoft dann könnt
ihr da auf jeden fall schneller
durchlaufen
bz wenn ihr dann manchmal so gegen die
wand läuft oder so macht durch die bahn
holzplatten beziehungsweise wenn ihr
fallen bauen wollte mit einem stein
button geht das deutlich schneller als
mit einem holzboot der vierte feld wurde
mir zugesendet von oskar schimanski und
zwar hab ich hier dafür jetzt erstmal so
einen kleinen fernseher aufgebracht für
jetzt das eingeblendet seht also da
werden wir jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen fernsehen schauen weil ich das
ganze in einer anderen welt gemacht habe
weil ich keine lust hatte mir diese welt
kaputt zu machen
es geht nämlich darum dass tnt unter
wasser zwar kein schaden macht wenn man
allerdings einen sand block in das tier
einfallen lässt macht die unter wasser
doch schaden das ist egal ob das auf
einer höhe ist mit dem erdboden oder ob
das 3 tief unter wasser sondern mit dem
ozean
wenn man ein land in ein team in ein so
angezündetes 10 tr einfallen lässt
dann macht das tnt trotzdem schaden uns
darstellt die umwelt und das hat jetzt
gerade in dem film hier gesehen deswegen
würde ich sagen wenn es euch gefallen
hat lasst einfach eine positive
bewertung da ich würde mich freuen wenn
wir irgendwie hatte ich schaffen wir
2000 daumen hoch dass wir auf jeden fall
kraft für diese folge minecraft ex weil
es auch relativ aufwendig war mit dem
kanton und dieses einwänden hier
schreibt perfekt per mail an kontakt
e-mail dort kommen hier nochmal das
geräusch falls es am anfang noch nicht
mitbekommen habt drei mal wenn jetzt
kennt schreibt seine kommentar eventuell
seid ihr im nächsten mai kräftig zeuge
dabei oder auch wenn dem effekt schreibt
und natürlich sagen einen wunderschönen
tag und wir sehen uns nachher baywa
rundschau